auf gotland dort fahren die panzer auf
soldaten mit maschinengewehren am
hafengelände von visby auf gotland
schwedens armee seit freitag soldaten
und waffen auf die ostseeinsel denn sie
ist von großer strategischer bedeutung
der völlig irre urlaubsgebiet für alle
schweben und jetzt plötzlich auch ein
mögliches konflikt kriegsgebiet peter
wilke ist genau dort auf gut
angst vor krieg jetzt auch in schweden
mitte letzter woche russland verlegt
plötzlich drei landungsschiffe in die
ostsee alle fragen sich was hat putin
vor die schwedische regierung befürchtet
einen angriff und reagiert seit freitag
werden hunderte soldaten und panzer nach
gotland verlegt die insel ist von
enormer strategischer bedeutung möchte
putin europa angreifen braucht er zuerst
diese insel das russische kaliningrad
liegt nur 300 kilometer entfernt deshalb
bereitet sich schweden auf den notfall
vor und lässt soldaten und panzer
fahrzeuge durch die hafenstadt visp
patroullieren bild ist vor ort das
militär ist schon lange hier stationiert
aber diese situation ist für die
bewohner neu
wir hatten seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
nicht mehr so viele militärische kräfte
in gotland natürlich sehen dass die
menschen wundern sich und sind ein
bisschen besorgt was wirklich passiert
diese besorgnis scheint nicht
unbegründet zu sein hochrangige
schwedische militärs machen sich auf den
weg nach gotland
heute bin ich auch stockholm nach
whiskey gekommen in dem flugzeug saßen
einige soldaten man an ihren abzeichen
sehen konnte waren zum zentralen
oberkochen ich glaube die nehmen das
sehr ernst ich habe ein aufrüsten in so
kurzer zeit noch nie gesehen
ein russischer angriff gilt bei den
einwohnern als auch in der schwedischen
politik als unwahrscheinlich doch das
säbelrasseln putins wird immer lauter
peter wicke jetzt auf gotland lasst uns
ein bisschen schauen dort in die herzen
der menschen auf gotland mensch das ist
so eigentlich das beste astrid lindgren
leben dort schafe gut landschafe und
plötzlich redet man dort nur noch über 1
über putin
ja kaida ist absolut recht das ist hier
eigentlich eine sehr idyllische region
auch momentan sehr kalt aber eben
typische schwedische landschaft sehr
idyllisch und da denkt man eigentlich
nicht an panzer die hier seit freitag
eben aufwand aber die schwedische
regierung hat sich dazu genötigt gesehen
eben weil russische landungsschiff in
der ostsee aufgetaucht sind dort neu
eingelaufen sind und deswegen wurden
jetzt die panzer und eben die hunderten
soldaten hingeschickt und das merkt man
auch auf jeden fall wir sind seit
gestern hier und schon wenn man mit der
fähre hier auf gotland ankommt erwarten
einen dort soldaten die einen kritisch
begutachten was ist hier los und wir
sind jetzt hier direkt an dem offenen
meer an der offenen ostsee auf der
anderen seite der insel und hier
patroullieren die soldaten auch mit
maschinengewehren durch eigentlich ganz
normale friedliche dörfer weil man eben
aufpassen möchte was da auf der ostsee
passiert ob da nicht die russen irgend
etwas im schilde führen peter wilke es
sieht aus wie bullerbü doch ist fahrende
panzer aus vielen herzlichen dank für
deine einschätzungen